[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho scelto questa canzone perché questa
estate mia sorella ha passato un momento
critico e la trovavo spesso ad ascoltare
questa canzone io pensavo che la
tranquillizzasse piaceva particolarmente
anche a me perché mi sembrava che il
tempo si fermasse cosa stupenda se
succedesse riuscire a far tantissime
nelle cose a cui tengo tra cui la mia
più grande passione quella del correre
il mio sogno più grande è quello di
entrare nella nazionale italiana di
atletica leggera e di partecipare alle
olimpiadi ma in gran parte di queste
cose io purtroppo non riesco a farle
perché la mia scuola occupa gran parte
del mio tempo
penserete beh sarà quando ritorni a casa
studi e poi vai a correre
e invece no perché io sono dislessica e
il mio tempo si misura in maniera
diversa da quella degli altri e gran
parte di queste cose non riesco nemmeno
a farle da sola infatti un giorno alla
settimana viene un'educatrice ad
aiutarmi a finire compiti per la
definizione di dislessia disturbo
specifico della lettura poi fa parte dei
dsa disturbi specifici
dell'apprendimento quindi una difficoltà
nell'imparare così the last riduzione al
mio diagnosi ma adesso ve lo spieghiamo
dominio sapete quando sia alle
elementari tutti i bambini leggono piano
e nessuno si arrabbia se tu sbagli una
parola se finisce qualche momento dopo
ma tutto all'improvviso e tutti iniziano
a correre e io invece rimanevo sempre
ferma nello stesso punto
e a me piaceva la velocità mi sentivo
sempre più frustrata da questo fatto che
vedevo i miei compagni correre sulle
pagine e invece io rimanevo ferma in un
punto
ecco i miei genitori lo hanno capito fin
da subito che ero dislessica infatti fin
da quando ero bambino sono andata da
tanti dottori che li aiutavano a
sistemare la mia pronuncia ad esempio
quando era una bambina non riuscivo a di
il ramarro marrone perché non riusciva a
dire
r ma nemmeno lesse infatti non riusciva
a dire il mio nome è cosa buffa no una
bambina che non sa dire il proprio nome
ecco andavo da questa dottoressa mi
ricordo chiara bionda mi stava simpatica
rarità e mi faceva fare questo esercizio
di metterla lingua contro i denti e
provare a dirla così sembra un po
divertente farlo se volete potete
provare
[Musica]
col tempo mi servì molto questo
esercizio
perché adesso so dire il ramarro marrone
ma come so dire il mio nome e state
tranquilli
ecco ora vi mostro una slide fate fatica
vero adesso invece viene mostro un'altra
sono sicura che la maggior parte di voi
avrà pensato o adesso sì che si capisce
come vi ho fatto vedere nella prima
slide è come vede una persona meno per
senza quando porta gli occhiali
ecco adesso volevo porvi due semplici
domande giudichereste mai una persona
solo perché porta gli occhiali oppure
pretendesse mai che questa persona
studiassi senza gli occhiali per
sentirsi come gli altri
io penso proprio di no perché è una
pazzia
ecco alzi la mano chi sa la porta gli
occhiali non barate tanto vi vedo tutti
vedete guardando gli occhiali non c'è
niente di quindi di regolarsi si ok
forse quando scoliamo la pasta ci si
appannano tutti non vediamo più dove va
via
dove va la pasta però con la disney ha
purtroppo non è la stessa cosa che
conobbi di dei modi di bu scompare tutto
ci sono persone che ti guardano come se
avesse una malattia contagiosa
beh volevo tranquillizzare tutti state
tranquilli non siamo contagiosi anzi se
provate a parlare con la persona
dislessica ma non solo
sono sicura che riuscirete ad ampliare
il vostro modo limitato di pensare
e se ci sono con le persone che dicono
che la dislessia una malattia
state certi che ci sono anche quelle
persone che dicono che la malattia che
la dislessia non esiste e che sia solo
una scusa per non fare e io veramente
non so chi odia di più ma ve lo
immaginate di dire un disse a un mio per
chi non deve portare gli occhiali e che
la sua solo pigrizia che si deve
impegnare di più ci sono a tantissimi
personaggi famosi che hanno avuto
successo pur essendo dislessici
ma io volevo precisare proprio perché
erano dislessici
ecco volevo farmi un esempio a intaglio
nardò da vinci walt disney steve jobs ma
avrete capito che non sono qui a
parlarvi di loro ma scoperto che c'è una
caratteristica che li accomuna non si
sono focalizzati su un loro problema che
in questa cosa era la dislessia
ma sono riusciti a sviluppare altre loro
caratteristiche e questo lo può fare
chiunque un dislessico disgrafico chi ne
ha più ne metta ma anche un semplice
essere umano
ecco io la penso in questo modo che la
dislessia ti dia l'opportunità di
sviluppare altre tue caratteristiche
proprio perché io sono dislessica ho
sviluppato le mie caratteristiche che li
possiamo chiamare tre super poteri fino
a quando sono bambina piccola sono
sempre stata una ragazza super furba che
ho sempre cercato la strada più veloce e
più comoda per arrivare alla soluzione
poi il pratico a livello agonistico
l'arrampicata sugli specchi riesco
sempre o quasi sempre non voglio darmi
troppa modestia a portare la ragione del
discorso verso la mia parte anche quando
so di aver torto marcio e infine o una
super memoria sono sicura che questo
super potere lo vorrebbe avere chiunque
riesca a ricordarmi un concetto
umanistico una data sentita così di
sfuggita in classe per una lunga
distanza di tempo bello eh
ecco volevo lasciarvi con questo
messaggio
che anche se siete dislessici anche se
sono dislessica di non abbandonare mai i
vostri sogni di non arrendervi davanti a
una piccola difficoltà anche se per voi
sembra veramente grande
ecco nessuno può dirvi che non
riuscirete mai nel lavoro dei propri
sogni nessuno ancora può dirmi hai sala
tu guarda non entrerà mai nella
nazionale no chi sei per dirmelo c'è
ecco la mia presentazione non ha una
fine state tranquilli a una metafora
finisco fra poco questo mio talk e ha un
piccolo passo verso la persona a cui
voglio essere un lungo cammino ma sono
sicura che riuscirò ad ottenere degli
ottimi di saw tassi con l'andare del
tempo voleva lasciarvi con un messaggio
per me è importante
domani quando vi alzate da letto pensate
a quello che sapete fare è quello in cui
vi sentite veloci e provate e trovato un
piccolo spazio per voi stessi oltre ai
vostri doveri quotidiani grazie
[Applauso]